robert mugabe hailed as an
anti-colonialist hero despised as an
autocrat and dictator at the time of
this video being produced Robert Mugabe
has just recently died aged 95 after 37
years as the Prime Minister and then
president of Zimbabwe the news of his
death have le become public and many of
you are asking us to cover his life
story and career so well here we are
obliging Robert Maga BAE's rise to power
is a similar story to that of many
rulers in the decolonization period it's
a story of a struggle for independence a
quest for national unity in societal
developments and then a gradual descent
into autocratic rule economic chaos and
violence Robert Mugabe was born on
February 21st 1924 in Kitana not far
from Harare now the capital city of
Zimbabwe but formally the administrative
center of Southern Rhodesia a recently
constituted self-governing British
colony at that time political and
economic power was firmly in the hands
of the white minority some 270,000
citizens who controlled the most fertile
land
conversely six million locals were
pushed into the colony's driest regions
making a hard living from subsistence
farming young Roberts was educated in a
school run by Catholic missionaries and
was by all accounts a studious and
hardworking child he later recalled that
he enjoyed solitude while looking after
a herd of cattle in the salt company of
a book robert's father a carpenter
abandoned the family when the boy was
only ten years old
that same year Roberts elder brother
died allegedly from a poisoning which
plunged his mother into a deep
depression interrupted only by violent
mood swings in addition to looking after
their farm and attending school Roberts
had to look after his mother he
developed a strong bonds with hers and
the extent of being bullied for being a
mummy's boy Robert continued his studies
into higher education from 1950 to 1952
he attended Fort Hare Academy in South
Africa thanks to a scholarship in this
period seep started to develop a
political conscience influenced by
socialism and nanti colonialism inspired
by a desire for independence from
British rule and by a willed
breakdown racial divisions apartheid was
becoming a tangible reality in Rhodesia
and neighboring South Africa and Robert
found inspiration in Gandhi Nehru and
the struggle for Indian self-rule Robert
eventually graduated as a teacher the
first of many academic achievements in
80 years he would attain degrees in law
administration and economics the same
year 1953 saw Southern Rhodesia merged
with the British protectorate of
Northern Rhodesia the resulting
Federation of Rhodesia and Nyasaland was
still under British colonial
administration Robert soon became Mr
Mugabe to his students after taking a
series of teaching positions first in
the north of the Federation a territory
which later became Zambia and then in
Ghana Mr Mugabe experiences in Ghana
were life changing on a personal level
he'd met and courted a colleague Sally -
the two marries in 1958 on a political
level Ghana was an eye opener for the
young teacher the West African country
was already independent a first taste of
free life from colonial rule he was
deeply impressed by the policies of
Ghana's first president Kwame Nkrumah
and his brand of African socialism this
ideology embraced established aspects of
socialism such as communal land
ownership and a planned economy but it
fused them with private initiatives and
acceptance of individualism and a
revival of pre-colonial African culture
Mugabe returns in Rhodesia in 1960
inspired by Coomer and encouraged by
Sally he took his first steps into anti
colonial activism he started campaigning
against the discrimination of the black
majority which granted him an invitation
to speak at the rally of the National
Democratic Party or NDP
the party leader Joshua comer was
impressed by the teacher and hired him
as publicity secretary for the NDP
unfortunately this alliance of two very
strong personalities was doomed to
failure
[Music]
the leadership and membership of the NDP
mirrored the makeup of the black
population in Rhodesia as it was divided
into two main ethnicities the Shona
majority and the Ndebele a minority
nekoma and most of the leaders belong to
the latter in 1963 the Shona clans
rebelled against nakumo led by Reverend
Nineveh nagisa tall and by Mugabe
himself the Reverend and the teacher
they formed a breakaway faction which
became known as the Zimbabwe African
National Union or Zanu the strong anti
colonial stance of the Czerny became a
cause for concern for Rhodesian
authorities in 1964 they cracked down on
the party leadership Mugabe satola and
other activists were convicted of
sedition and sentenced to harsh prison
terms that could extend up to 11 years
the bitterness of incarceration was only
made worse by news from outside magar
Bay's only child had died in Ghana in
1965 and he had been denied leave to
attend the funeral
during the same year British broke away
from the British Empire becoming an
independent country albeit without
international recognition power remains
firmly in the hands of the white
minority the struggle of Mugabe the
Xiongnu and the NDP it shifted in focus
the priority was no longer independence
from the British but rather an
established government led by the black
majority of the country while in prison
Robert Mugabe made the most of his time
by further advancing his education and
preparing for total leadership by the
early 1970s Mugabe was still playing
second fiddle to the reverends but
trouble it was stirring other party
members also incarcerated accused the
reverends of cooperating too closely
with white authorities in exchange for
prison privileges Sidel was eventually
Elstad and magar they swooped in
becoming the head of Zanu in 1965 after
the end of his prison term
Magali fled to Mozambique with the help
of a white nun very joins these enla
guerrilla force that had been harassing
the Rhodesian government since 1964 this
was a part of the Rhodesian bush war
also known as these in bobwhite
liberation struggle and let me tell you
this is a very complicated war so get
your notepads out on the one hand you
had the Rhodesian government hampered by
UN sanctions because of the lack of
international recognition but it was
supplied in secret by the South Africa
governments on the other side you had
Xan la force or Zimbabwe African
National Liberation Army a fill
with Zanna the party of sital and gob a
the sanli operated from Mozambique and
was supported and supplied by China in
the third corner there was Zipporah
these in Bob Way People's Revolutionary
Army operating from Zambia their back is
where the Soviet Union and their
political leader was Joshua nakumo who
had now founded his own party Zabu and
it's interesting to note here the sanli
Zipporah dichotomy reflected the larger
sino-soviet split a major turning point
in the Cold War but let's stay grounded
in Rhodesia shall we Mugabe did not
actively participate in the fighting his
role was more political he was the voice
of the ideology he would motivate the
fighters and swell their ranks through
propaganda and recruitment it is
generally recognized that Zipporah was
in fact more of an active military force
while Maga B's shandler was more
interested in sewing dissent and
disobedience inside Rhodesia the
complexity of the situation it was
thankfully reduced when Mugabe and
Nicola were forced by their followers to
accept an uneasy alliance the Patriotic
Front the two leaders did not actively
cooperate but simply accepted each
other's existence and avoided inviting
across their separate factions while the
insurgency against the Rhodesian
government continued the stage was being
set for a future conflict between the
two rebel leaders a CIA analyst noted
how the two tried to upstage each other
Mugabe visited Havana in 1977 to seek
support from Fidel Castro and possibly
extend a hand to the Soviets this
worried new como who also flew to Cuba
in November of 1978 to prevent the rival
from snatching Soviet favors the door
they was finally nearing its end in late
1979 the British government mediated a
peace deal between the Patriotic Front
and Rhodesia this agreement put an end
to the war sanctioned the independence
of Zimbabwe and pushed the relatively
obscure Mugabe front and center on the
international stage in early 1980 Mugabe
returns from his exile to Harare and
called for the first democratic election
of the newly independent state of
Zimbabwe Mugabe he was one of the
candidates of course and he became prime
minister with a 57 percent majority one
step after another the former teacher
had reached the top
[Music]
so they might now be wondering what was
Maga BAE's victory a fair and
transparent one as ruled by the British
observers well Maga they had certainly
built a following as a liberation hero
and he could rely on the vote of the
Shona majority but it is also claimed
that Maga Bayes guerrilla fighters
intimidated many voters into picking the
right candidate by forcing them to
attend indoctrination sessions called
Hungry's miyabi's rule was marked by
similar crafty methods his first rival
Joshua nakumo is invited to join the
newly formed cabinet as Home Affairs
Minister which might seem pretty
generous right but it's actually not new
comers powers were purposefully reduced
and he was denied any authority over
rural local governments and very
importantly over the special branches of
the police
Nicolle Maeve is a minister he had no
muscle this move was however in line
with Miguel's public face the face of
reconciliation the young state was rife
with divisions Magali versus nakumo
Shona versus Ndebele a black versus
white and yet the Prime Minister invited
everybody to remain calm
respect your opponents and do nothing
that will disturb the peace with us now
all of us work for unity whether you
have won the election or not speaking of
unity Mugabe was steering Zimbabwean
sheep becoming a one-party state under
the Zanu Patriotic Front or zanu-pf and
say one-party state not tolerate
opposition so despite all the Grands
talk and overtures to former rivals
Makka Bay was preparing to crack down
hard on mekomo and his followers in the
Ndebele a minority in August 1981 Mugabe
invited military instructors from North
Korea to train his crack troops the
fifth Brigade they would be known as the
GU kurohagi a Shona phrase meaning the
rain which washes away the chaff this
phrase would become the name of the most
infamous operation now as we're going to
hear about in a minute in February of
1982 a police inspection discovered a
cache of hidden arms in a farm owned by
one of Nokomis companies this was the
perfect pretext to accuse in a coma of
plotting a coup and remove him from the
cabinet next in January 1983 Mugabe
unleashed his full-scale offensive
against Nokomis followers the new de
bellas living in Matabeleland or Western
Zimbabwe the fifth
the rain swept through the region and
washed away what Maga they considered to
be the chaff according to a report from
Zimbabwe is Catholic Commission for
justice and peace the brigade was
responsible for mass murders beatings
and property burnings in the areas where
Nokomis supporters lived within six
weeks more than 2,000 civilians had died
hundreds of homesteads have been burns
and many more thousands of civilians had
been beaten most of the dead they were
killed in public executions involving
between 1 and 12 people at a single time
villagers frequently report being forced
to sing songs praising zanu-pf while
dancing on the mass graves of their
families and fellow villagers killed and
buried minutes earlier the operation in
the West had escalated into a full-scale
genocide or massacre the atrocities
continued until December 1987 when
Mugabe and nakumo reached another
tentative reconciliation by then it is
estimated that between 20 and 80,000
under Bello civilians had been murdered
while the atrocities went on in marbella
lands maga bay was consolidating his
grip on power in Harare in 1985
Zimbabweans had calls to vote for a new
parliaments the why minority was
constitutionally granted 20 seats in the
chambers and in the Aryan dismiss party
won all twenty of them mr. Smith's have
been the last white prime minister of
Rhodesia who had vowed that the black
majority would never rule this country
perceiving this as a thrash magar they
sought to reinforce his power base as
much as possible so he dissolved what a
little remains of Nokomis party and
merged it with his own zanu-pf with an
unbeatable majority in parliament Smeg
are they in 1987 moved to legislate his
lone leadership he managed to win a
majority vote ratifying a change to the
Constitution
this amendment eliminated the largely
ceremonial president's office and
created a new much more powerful
position for himself the executive
president this was a title which
combined the roles of head of state head
of the government and commander-in-chief
of the Armed Forces in case any of you
had not yet realized Mugabe had just
legitimized his own dictatorship over
Zimbabwe and yet this was also his
period of maximum popularity both at
home and abroad Mugabe dedicated
enormous slices of the budget to
education and health care his policies
managed to revive the economy and
develop urbanization in the country he
even introduced anti-corruption laws
known as the leadership code this
limited zanu-pf cadres from only more
than 50 acres of land Zimbabwe was
rapidly developing and Mugabe also had
private affairs to take care of in
January 1992 his wife sally died of
kidney failure in 1996 Robert Mugabe
married his second wife Grace Maura foo
a former secretary in the presidential
office and 41 years is jr. mcgaubey and
grace had had an affair since at least
1990 and their first child a girl called
Bona
was in fact born that same year
according to him McCarthy had asked
Sally's approval the marriage it was
childless and he wanted to sire a child
before his own mother died maybe Mona
could be counted among the so called
born freeze these were the new
generation of Zimbabweans born after the
dissolution of Rhodesia
many of them were ready to enter the
labor market at the end of the 1990s
having benefited from agaves increased
spending on education they were now
realizing that the country could not
offer
the quantity and quality of jobs they
were trained for the born frees lend
their support to a new party the
Movement for Democratic Change led by
former Labour leader Morgan Sanger a and
with this Maga BAE was about to face a
new decade of Tamil in February 2000
Raghava called for a referendum to
ratify a new constitution which would
have solidified even more his grip on
power the president was expecting an
easy victory but the Movement for
Democratic Change which was getting more
and more popular handed in a sound
defeat in the polling stations Megami
could not accept this and he accused the
MDC members of being lackeys of the
white farmers who had in fact openly
financed the party the WHI minority of
farmers and entrepreneurs made an easy
target for the leader who had always
ruled on a platform of anti-colonialism
and anti capitalism this minority was so
small that it could hardly pose a threat
it was about 70,000 citizens over a
total of 13 million and yet Maccabi
accused them of being dangerous agents
of British colonialism things got even
worse for Mugabe when the June 2000
parliamentary elections martes a
relative victory for the opposition the
MDC did not win the majority of seats
but with a good 57 out of 150 they could
leave a mark on legislation it just
seems like 2000 was the year when the
president could not capture break
another group raised their voices in
dissent as well the veterans of the war
of independence theoretically great
supporters of magar they but now
disgruntled as their pension funds had
been embezzled by corrupt officials the
veterans sought compensation by forcibly
occupying farms most of them operated by
the white minority Maga they went with
the flow encouraging the vets to claim
the lands as their own from his
perspective this must have been an easy
alternative to actually having to sort
out some sort of alternative pension
funds ironically redistribution of land
had been one of the priorities of maga
base government's after independence and
yet the issue that just sat there for
decades means Mugabe nor the white
farmers not even the British mediators
apparently were interested in sorting it
out in 2000 a full 20 years after
independence 4,500 white farmers still
owned more than 50 percent of Zimbabwe
and farm lands it seems like the
uprising of the veterans finally gave
maga be the motivation to complete the
land reform
in worst possible way though the gamma
is tacit consent to occupy the farm soon
turned into active complicity his
supporters organized armed squads to
invade the farms and chase away their
white owners over the following two
years almost all the white owned farm
lands had been redistributed to 300,000
black families now many of these farms
were assigned to competent commercial
farmers but many others went to reward
mcGarvie loyalists who had no experience
or any interest in working the lands to
use a Maoist analogy this great
agricultural leap forward eventually
caused more problems than benefits many
farms fell into disuse due to black and
modern equipment fertilizers efficient
irrigation or just plain incompetence
food shortages became common in the
country although the government painted
them as a consequence of drought other
leaders of the African Union they
started to pressure magar they into
revising his policies or even retiring
but Mugabe would cling like a barnacle
to his presidential seat I'm not
retiring I will never never go into
exile I fought for Zimbabwe and when I
die I will be buried in Zimbabwe nowhere
else in 2008 a new season of elections
proved to the world just how tough this
barnacle could be in March opposition
leader Morgan Tsvangirai claims victory
in a presidential vote but Mugabe claims
there had not been an official count yet
this was delayed four weeks until
madhavi's officials announced that there
hadn't been a clear Victor the
authorities scheduled further rounds of
voting but in the lead-up to the vote
Mugabe security forces launched a
campaign of intimidation against the
opposition party the MDC this went as
far as beating and killing opposition
supporters spanger I had no choice but
to seek refuge in the Dutch embassy in
Harare from where he announced his
withdrawal from the election in the
subsequent rounds of voting Magali
was the only candidate and surprisingly
beat 185 percent of the vote as he had
done in the past regard sought to
neutralize his opponents by absorbing
them into his cabinet Morgan Tsvangirai
was sworn in as Prime Minister although
it was clear that the executive and
military power was fully concentrated in
the garbage hands in the following 2013
elections Maga babe no surprise was the
clear winner yet again there as well as
printed polling cards stating who do you
want to be presidents a Robert Mugabe in
a gray suit or the
in a blue suit your call it is clearly
both as a blue suit is not appropriate
for even in social engagements but the
point is moot by this time maga Bey had
famously ditched formal suits for
colorful outfits and loud headgear
whatever he wore after his victory
President Mugabe decided to end his
arrangements with spanger I who returns
the opposition so I'm going to backtrack
for a moment now to take a closer look
at Zimbabwe economy under Mugabe in the
early 2000s it always been an autocrat
but at least in the 1980s and 1990s some
of his reforms that ensured better
standards of living for Zimbabwe ins but
after the ousting of the white farmers
Maga BAE's economic policies they became
farcical incompetence the collapse of
Zimbabwe farming system and a negative
impact on the rest of the economy this
food became scarce its price increased
while farmers have less cash to spend on
goods
moreover Mugabe had involved his
military in Congo civil war a conflict
so complex and not even going to try to
explain it here so as the government got
deeper and deeper into debt Maga BAE's
central bank reactors in the worst
possible way quantitative easing this
essentially is printing money to pay off
debts and conversate the war veterans
who had not benefited from the land
distribution as any citizen of the
Vanara Republic could tell you this can
only create catastrophic inflation which
hits at a rate of 231 million percent
the currency had to be issued in notes
as large as the 100 trillion Zimbabwean
dollar bill in u.s. dollars it was about
40 cents the increase in prices had also
affected housing many citizens in urban
areas were unable to pay rent and so
were forced to live in improvised
shelters the garbage solution was simply
to get rid of these shanty towns across
him Bob Waze matrice cities this was
called Operation Moran BOTS Vina wrought
Drive out of the rubbish large-scale
police operation which harassed bullied
and coerced 700,000 residents into
moving into the countryside from 2008 to
2013 the coalition with spanger I had
had some positive effects in carving
inflation but since Mugabe reasserted
complete control in 2013 he returns to
his former inflation inducing policies
but how long
last in the second half of the 2010 some
employment in Zimbabwe rose to 80
percent the public health system wants
the best in Africa had collapsed and yet
Mugabe grace and their family appeared
to spend lavishly on luxury goods and
travel frequently to the Far East both
the shopping sprees and to seek
treatments and expensive private clinics
in 2014 apparently inspired by grace
Maga they removed his vice-president
Joyce Maduro and replaced her with
staunch loyalists Emerson Managua this
move coincided with the elevation of
grace to a leadership post in the
zanu-pf the ruling party it appeared to
be that Maccabiah was setting the stage
for grace to succeed him as the new
executive president the first lady if
she was not a popular candidate
especially amongst the military on the
7th of November 2017 shortly before new
presidential elections magar they fired
his vice presidents the military saw
this as a sign of Graces impending
appointment to the vice presidency one
week later the generals occupied her
re-arrested the Maga days and placed
them under house arrest it was clearly a
military coup although military
spokesman described it as a bloodless
correction vice president Managua was
sworn in as presidents in that very same
month Robert and grace they were allowed
to live in relative calm inside their 24
bedroom home in Harare and even to
frequently travel to Singapore Mugabe
was being treated there for a long-term
illness
apparently cancer back in 2019 President
Managua revealed that Robert Mugabe had
been hospitalized in Singapore for the
past few months then on Friday the 6th
of September he announced that former
President Mugabe now aged 95 had died in
Singapore it is with the utmost sadness
that I announced the passing on of
Zimbabwe's founding father and former
president's comrade Robert Mugabe maga
there was an icon of liberation a
pan-africanist who dedicated his life to
the emancipation and empowerment of his
people his contribution to the history
of our nation and continent will never
be forgotten and on that well we can
agree his contribution the political
violence ethnic cleansing corruption and
mismanagement will certainly never be
forgotten so I really hope you found
that video interesting if you did please
you hit that thumbs up button below
don't forget to subscribe to this
channel for more just like this also
we've got a new channel it's called
Geographics it's sort of very much in
this biographic format but it's about
geography please find that linked to
below go check it out and as always
thank you for watching
[Music]